bis merkel vor geschossen laut
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunkanstalten
sind das alles diskriminierungsfreie
möglichkeiten menschen zu beleidigungen
sprachpolizei der öffentlich-rechtlichen
darüber müssen wir rechnen sprechen mit
alexander von schönburg bei uns im
studio was ist deine meinung zu diesem
etwas doch kuriosen post den wir dagegen
haben guten morgen dieser posting dem
liegt ja eine sendung zugrunde in dem
tipps gegeben worden wie man
gewaltfrei
beleidigen kann und ehrlich gesagt ist
es zu früh morgens jetzt für mich um
mich der resonanz waren sich aufzuregen
im grunde im grunde ist das anliegen wie
ja überhaupt das anliegen dieser ganzen
block bewegung eigentlich sehr rührend
und auch sehr nachvollziehbar und sehr
wichtig denn es geht ja darum einfach
die sensibilität dafür zu steigern dass
wir durch unbedachte äußerungen oft
vielleicht leute
beleidigen können oder diskriminieren
können und im grunde ist es ja etwas
wirklich richtig ist aber problem ist
dass deshalb dass diese vogue dieser
burg zeitgeist das halt so waren sich
überdreht und das so belehrend davor
kommen und so unbarmherzig auch
daherkommt und vor allem auch alle die
dann davon abweichen sofort wegschiebt
als die vollidioten ich habe
komischerweise in einer in zeitung einen
artikel gelesen über ein neues buch über
die dummheit und da hat heißt es
dummheit ist keine frage der intelligenz
sondern des charakters und stieß es
irgend es steht der dummheit ist vor
allem mal zu einem diese unhinterfragt
bahre überzeugung in besitz der wahrheit
zu sein und zwar ohne zweifel und das
ist ja das ist so ein bisschen das
problem und weil mir jetzt aufs
beleidigen zurückkommen ich finde
wir müssen aufpassen einerseits taktvoll
sein ist natürlich immer wichtig
andererseits müssen wir aufpassen dass
wir nicht ständig so auf diesen
eierschalen gehen weil das führt noch
ein bisschen dazu dass man dann und das
ist richtig gefährlich dass man dann zu
hause oder mit seiner familie oder mit
seinen engsten freunden anders spricht
als als man zum beispiel hier im studio
und das oder dass das wird dann das wird
dann sozusagen doppelt doppelt standard
und das ist richtig gefährlich finde ich
und ich finde auch und das ist eine
sache die für mich sehr wichtig ist denn
es betrifft mein leben ich möchte auch
blöde sachen sagen können und dann
entschuldigt man sich dafür und dann ist
auch wieder gut und im diese die im
moment ist es so ein bisschen zu wissen
so unbarmherzig wenn jemand mal
irgendetwas schlechtes sagt dann ist er
wird er im internet fertig gemacht und
dann ist er auch für den rest des lebens
verbrannt ich finde es übrigens auch für
für den geist wichtig man muss auch
unsinn sagen können das ist wie gesagt
für mich besonders wichtig wenn ich kein
unsinn mehr sagen kann man musste unsinn
ja auch abgleichen können mit dem mit
anderen denken du sagst du mal
irgendeinen quatsch untersagt hat und du
wirst du wieder korrigiert und alle nur
noch erscheinen gehen wird das gehirn
beschädigt dass das gehirn es auch das
ist für mich sehr gefährlich wir sollten
alle toleranter sein was das angeht aber
es geht da das gesagt um gewaltfreie
beleidigung sind beleidigungen nicht
immer gewaltfrei na ja also ich hab mir
jetzt mal ein paar beispiele rausgesucht
die können uns vielleicht vielleicht
anschauen
gucken wir mal was da so dabei ist ich
hatte noch in erinnerung zum beispiel
nach trat hier sehen wir jetzt noch bis
nelke war eben da flachwurzler hupen
hans
wirth du solche beleidigungen überhaupt
benutzen also ich fürchte mich gerne in
mundart weil dem mundart kann man die
schönsten dinge sagen und das ist jeder
sofort versteht
werden
ich finde beleidigen hat auch etwas
einfach damit zu tun dass man auch mal
dass dem freien lauf lässt was immer was
in einem vorgeht ja und da sagst du ja
danach wird ein flachwurzler so was
können wir noch gar nicht so was kommen
da gar nicht im kopf das müsste ich doch
alles erst mal neu lernen sozusagen als
beleidigung weil das ist wirklich nichts
was mit meinem normalen sprachgebrauch
jetzt so flüssig ist und ich glaube auch
nicht nur ja also wird das ist eben so
ein bisschen wie gefahr dass man
plötzlich so mit seinem handbuch durchs
leben geht und schaut und nachschaut war
aber regelmäßig was kann ich noch tun
das wird das führt zu unglaublicher
verklemmtheit und verklemmtheit führt
eben auch zu neurosen also
das ist ja überhaupt dieses problem dass
wir in einer zeit leben die leute waren
sie sind wohl jeder sehr sehr schnell
verletzt ist und das ist dass das
psychologische probleme ein berühmter
amerikanischer psychiater der johnson
hague hat darüber regener gesagt wenn
wir dieses kultur immer wieder fördern
dass alle leute beleidigt sind dann
kommt da so ein belohnungs mechanismus
in gang das heißt je mehr du beleidigt
du sie mehr du dich beleidigt fühlt
desto mehr willst du auch belohnt dafür
durch aufmerksamkeit dass du beleidigt
was das führt dazu dass man ständig
schauen mich beleidigt und am ende sind
wir alle so dünnhäutig und zum ein und
plötzlich hat jeder in sich hinein und
sarah ich bin so wie ich bin so verletzt
und letztlich fördert das natürlich
neurosen weil du ständig dann plötzlich
anfängt darüber nachzudenken wie wie
verletzt zuständig ist wenn wir so
streng sind mit zu strengen werden mit
unseren maßstäben dann müssen wir sehr
sehr viel cancel und am ende haben wir
nur noch die teletubbies im fernsehen
denn ich ein letztes beispiel john
lennon wenn man jetzt wenn ich euch auf
listen würde die frauenfeindlichen
bemerkungen von john lennon dann wäre
hätte dieser mann im jahr 2022 keine
drei minuten in der öffentlichkeit
überlebt der mann wäre sofort gecancelt
worden und wollte ihr unter die musik
der beatles auskommt nein natürlich
nicht